Okay, there would be four possible combinations. Because
chromosome pairs are split up during meiosis, right?
We learned that a couple exercises ago. An
then that means that this pair of chromosome two,
we could get the dominant lactase allele in
one gamete and the recessive lactase allele in another
gamete. Well this gamete is also going to
have one chromosome from the chromosome four pair and
it could get either the recessive allele or
the dominant dwarfism allele. But it could also have
gone the other way, where the dominant dwarfism
allele ended up with the dominant lactase allele, and
the recessive lactase allele ended up with the
recessive dwarfism allele. You will notice that each of
these four genotypes is distinct and entirely possible
based on the process of the law of segregation.